now last weekend the mayor of greater
manchester said
that northern england is in a hotel
california lockdown and it doesn't look
like anyone
is going to be able to leave anytime
soon millions of people are already
living under postcode lockdowns
including people in steli bridge in
greater manchester where we're joined
from there by labour's shadow work and
pension secretary jonathan reynolds
thank you very much for
being on the program mr reynolds so on
monday
the government is reportedly going to be
introducing this three-tier
lockdown system where people in the
third tier which could well include
people in your own constituency
will face the toughest level of
restrictions potentially closing
pubs stopping households mixing anywhere
is that something labor supports
good morning sophie look the first thing
i just have to put on the record
is the level of anger and frustration
that exists in towns and constituencies
like mine the way this is happening so
there's been
leaks to newspapers there's been no
consultation with local leaders this is
not the way
to do things people feel they're being
treated with contempt and not with
respect and that is simply not good
enough
to answer your question directly the
fact is there are going to have to be
further measures and the reason for that
is the government have lost control
right they've lost control of the
messaging they've lost control of
uh test and trace they've lost control
of the virus unfortunately
and that means we're going to have to
have further measures that wasn't
inevitable
that time we we got from the lockdown
and from the development of
what should have been an effective test
and trade system should have meant we
don't have to get to that position
but the crucial point is this further
restrictions
have to come with economic support the
situation for businesses here in my
constituency is not acceptable how can
they plan
for next week they've had nine weeks of
very very restrictive
local restrictions that's had a huge
impact on them of course it has
and now we find out we will learn
tomorrow what is going on so the prime
minister's got to get a grip of this
he's got to come to parliament but
crucially any further restrictions
must come with appropriate levels of
support for businesses and people i mean
to be fair the government has announced
more support for businesses and people
the chancellor said the government will
pay two thirds of people's wages
if businesses are forced to close i mean
this is unprecedented the government's
never stepped in before to pay people's
wages
um are you demanding too much
no it's not good enough what the
government have it out so let's be clear
for nine weeks now in constituencies
like this one the restrictions have been
that you cannot socialize indoors with
people who aren't your immediate
family so you add that to for instance
the curfew how can a restaurant or a
business
trade viably in that environment of
course don't forget
that we're now several so many months
into this crisis that all the businesses
have have the debt they have to get with
the bounce-back loans at the beginning
they've had very
uh poor trading for for most of this
year they're in a very difficult
position so no the support is not enough
and it must
get better but at the same time there
are other things the government could do
so we haven't yet got
sick pay for everybody the the payment
that was announced to 500 pounds for
people
self-isolating only about one in eight
workers are eligible for that
there's the money they underspend in the
grants that were given to councils that
could be
packaged up again and give councils the
power to give that out again so there is
much more
that needs to be done but you know
frankly we're in this position
because of the government's inability to
control this properly and i'm afraid
that does mean more restrictions for
people
and they deserve support if they're
asked to obey those restrictions going
forward
i'm interested in your insight as a
local mp
uh in an area that has faced these
additional restrictions as you said for
a long time 10 weeks or so and i spoke
to anti-birmingham last weekend and he
said he thinks that the government is on
the verge of losing
the north of england do you think that
there is a real concern now that people
might just stop
following the rules that people have
reached their breaking point reaching a
breaking point
it is a worry to be frank so at the
beginning you know we talked i think
in the country about how there might be
lockdown fatigue um
that is definitely more of a feature but
you know the reason for that sophie has
been
if you take the last two and a half
months here in greater manchester what
you've seen is
very significant restrictions on
people's lives can't see family members
can't visit
loved ones in care homes you know
businesses pubs can't trade properly
and at the same time no additional
support
and as well as that the infection rate
going from you know 50 infections
in a hundred thousand to in this area
now over 200 infections in a hundred
thousand and in central manchester
over 500 infections so people are
looking at it and saying
well we just don't think the
government's got a grip on this but we
do need them
to follow the rules you know we still
want the government to succeed we want
them to get
a grip on this but they're just not
doing that at the minute and part of
that is
you know how contracts have been handed
out for test and trace
getting nowhere near what we need to be
i i look you know just
over there to wales and and what they've
been able to do is far superior to what
we've got
in england so there are real lessons the
government have got to learn they've got
to get a grip on this because they are
starting
to lose people and there is resentment
to be frank there's resentment about the
north-south
divide in some of these local
restrictions and you can see that coming
across
so unless the prime minister gets a grip
of this it will get even more difficult
i'd appreciate a really clear answer on
this next question the 10 p.m rule where
pubs restaurants have to close at 10 pms
come in for an awful lot of criticism
some people saying it's
counterproductive
there's a vote on it next week does
labour support the 10 pm rule
well to be honest the 10 pm rule is
going to be rendered obsolete by what we
hear
tomorrow because we'll probably see
that's not that's
genuinely not what i asked as well does
labour back the 10 pm rule or oppose it
we think we have to be restricted to
hospitality yes but the crucial point is
there's got to be support with those
restrictions in terms of where
affections are
sorry i do apologize for coming in again
but i'm still
genuinely not clear does labour back the
10 pm rule or not
yes we back restrictions in hospitality
as long as they've got
the economic support that should go with
that but as i say i think what we'll see
on monday is
the situation will move on anyway for so
many businesses the crucial thing is
environment for business like a pub
right now it's not a viable one
and that is the problem that the
government has to solve so you'd vote
in favor of the 10 pm rule
it's not a vote specifically on the 10
pm rule it's a vote on all of the
package
of measures affecting areas like this
now when the infection rate is as it is
in a constituency like mine
you can't be arguing for less
restrictions that's just not feasible if
you look at where
that progress is going so it's not a
specific vote on the 10 pm rule
but on the package of measures overall
and as i say the reality is
we have got to accept that more measures
will happen because the government have
lost control of the situation the
crucial thing is
making sure there's the right level of
support to go with those restrictions
because at the minute there isn't
and that's what's not acceptable okay
now later on the program we're going to
be speaking to the housing secretary
robert generic
labour's calling for an investigation
into him what's that about
well basically the measures that
the department of communities local
government have been offering to local
towns the regeneration money
um robert generic is obviously in charge
of that as the as the secretary of
state that's a program that towns like
mine here in staley bridge very much
wanted to be
part of and we didn't get the money and
now we find out that where that money
has gone
has been very much directed by ministers
to what look like
uh conservative electoral battlegrounds
so we always knew when the data came out
you could compare
the different parts of greater
manchester for instance that got the
money and it wasn't clear why we didn't
get it but a place like cheadle down the
road did but now we know that ministers
have directly tried to influence that
they have
uh in robert generic's case sat on the
local board
that then made the application to and
then tried to cover that up so the whole
question
has always been of quite a murky one as
to how this money was allocated
the secretary of state has questions to
answer an investigation is the right way
forward